actual infrastructure and Commissioner
Lord of Darkness and all the donors good
amuse you and evening 1.7 billion is
that enough it's good down payment what
we need is to get game on seriously
improving the quality of Metro bus and
other public transport systems which
serve our cities and linking the city
centers which is fine I've done quite
well and they're going to do very well
in the future out of hs2 and other big
spending on on on big rail projects in
particular linking them to the suburbs
and to less prosperous towns in in their
regions this is a good downpayment what
we now need to see is proper plans
brought forward and when you see this
sum of money increased over time so that
we can really invest in getting Metro
systems in place like the one that
London has London has an astonishingly
good metro system
arguably the best in the world linking
it's really highly important a city
center well the jobs are to the places
where people live and we now need to see
those sorts of transport systems put in
place in all of the other major cities
of the country when you published your
wish list last week of projects that
you'd like to see I mean you want to see
this present between Northampton and
Oxford essentially don't you Oxford
Milton Keynes Cambridge Northampton will
share in that too but these are three of
the fastest growing and most important
cities in the country a hugely important
jobs in terms of the value of the jobs -
astonishingly great universities Oxford
and Cambridge world leading universities
but also Milton Keynes one of the
fastest growing cities in the country
now as an economy the size of
Liverpool's and what we need is a lot
more housing in this area particularly
lower cost housing because the big
problem at the moment is that there are
loads of jobs not enough places for
people to live and we need good
transport systems in place to make that
possible lot of viewers in the north of
England will say hang on these are all
places in the south and south east of
england again what about the north the
Crossrail of the north scheme which one
link Liverpool Manchester Leeds hull
that is just as important as the
Crossrail scheme in London and that
needs to be part of these plans for the
future and we've said that loud and
clear
what we need is hs2 is good to be
developed over the next 15 years that is
a 60 billion investment in transforming
the connections between the three
largest conurbations of the country
London the West Midlands and the
northwest
it will also serve West Yorkshire as
well now what we need to do is to join
up those northern conurbations as well
and if we can do that then we'll have a
really first-rate transport system for
the 21st century and of course one of
the big projects that you've been
pressing for for a number of years the
third runway Heathrow and still feels
like it's a long way from ever happening
doesn't it it is 20 years we've spent
debating whether this should happen it
now does need to happen you know today
it was announced and a heartrending
decision that the European Medicines
Agency which has been here in London is
going to amsterdam schiphol airport in
amsterdam has six runways shelter Gaulle
Airport in Paris has four runways when I
was transport secretary I went to the
opening of the fourth runway in
Frankfurt London Heathrow hugely
important to the economy of Britain our
only hub airport has two runways we have
got to get real as a country
particularly if we're going to be going
down the brexit route
you cannot trade with the wider world if
you can't get to it if Heathrow Airport
has a big sign up outside saying fall no
more business this will do huge damage
to us as a country and we now need to
take the decision which is basically
just logjams in Parliament at the moment
Parliament needs to decide to do this
third runway and the mini to build it
well we have you very very briefly you
met Michel Barney last week what do you
think of the way he's ratcheting up the
rhetoric right now well in the national
interest let's hope the David Davis
Michel Barney Barney can strike a deal
but you know as this national tragedy
rolls on I think the best thing to do by
far is simply to stop it and to say to
the people you were sold a pup a year
ago in the referendum you cannot have
greater prosperity outside the European
Union let's call a halt to this and ask
the people for their view as to whether
we're actually better staying in after
all and then maybe we'll get the
medicines agency back again they haven't
actually moved it to Amsterdam yet as
people realize what's happening there is
a last chance for us to stop this
national lunacy